okay would you like to see a magic trick
always okay so these are a set of four
little sticks that I've got here they've
got numbers on them they're called the
mental logs and I'm gonna use them to do
a super-fast mental calculation which
I'm sure you'll enjoy very much so
you're allowed to order these in
whatever order you want to so that's
what the middle two and this end both n
T's okay that one and that one yep so
they've got four faces on each one so
what you want to do I want to turn the
first one like that yep okay like that
unlike that so you've now created four
four digit numbers across the top so
you've got four thousand nine hundred
and fifty nine across the top there and
then three other numbers as well and I
would like you to add up those four
numbers 49:59 okay I'll stop you there
before you press equals so I'm gonna
tell you the total is going to be twenty
two thousand four hundred and eighty six
okay yeah it's a magic trick yes so this
is this is a nice little it's actually a
really classic magic trick is the thing
you can buy in magic shops and it's a
hundred percent maths and it's just it's
adorable once you figure out how this
works it's actually super easy to do and
the mass is really really satisfying the
way that it actually works so I mean if
if people want to try and figure out how
this works you can have a look at them
you can look at the numbers on them
they've all got different sets of
numbers on each side the the numbers it
doesn't really matter what they are but
there is a pattern to it so you might be
able to look at some of those and maybe
spot some of the patterns in there but I
will explain what it is that's going on
here so on here these numbers have been
chosen very carefully so the the third
number there is the one that I'm
interested in and that's the one that I
use to work out the total of all the
others so in fact I can do this with
fewer than four I can do it with two
rods instead so if I pick these two rods
like this I would say the total there is
275 and the reason I know that is
because I'm taking this number and put
the two at the start taking this number
and
- - from that one if I had these three
rods together I would say the total is
2777 because I'm putting a two at the
star and I'm subtracting two from that
last number and in fact if I take these
and change them so that they're all
facing different ways like that yep
so that'll be the total for those and
you can do it with one so the total
there would be 21 because I put a two at
the start and I subtract two from the
last digit and the reason why this works
is it's just lovely so if you look at
the numbers on here the numbers except
for that third one will always add up to
the same total so here I've got four
nine and five total of 18 again here
I've got nine four and five here I've
got three seven and eight total of 18
and again three eight and seven and the
same thing works on any one of these so
there I've got eight three and seven
total 1872 and nine total 18 and that
will always work and what this means is
that if you have your four columns of
numbers and you're adding them all
together you get 18 in each of the three
columns plus whatever that extra digit
is so what I'm essentially adding up is
whatever the number in the third row is
and we'll come back to that later but
I've got this one is 2 2 7 2 - yep okay
okay so yeah you'll get a five digit
number if you've got four columns and so
what I've essentially got here is I've
got 18 in the right-hand column and in
this column I've got 18 again but
because it's the tens column I've
effectively got 180 and in the next
column I've got 1,800 and in the next
column I've got 18 thousand and if I add
all of those together you some live
maths live very very easy maths I get
this and this number is 20 thousand
minus two so if I take this row which is
the only row I haven't used yet add 20
thousand and subtract two I'll get the
same as if I'd added up all of the
numbers and in that case it's the same
as putting a two at the start and then
minus thing to from the number at the
end so actually nice and and this is why
it works with any number of columns as
well because the exact same thing
happens
but you know I just don't have this here
so I'd have one nine nine eight and the
same thing would work and also there's
there's an extra hidden thing built into
these which i think is quite nifty which
is that if you put the rods in this
order I can tell you the total on the
back is twenty eight thousand six
hundred and thirty-two so if I flip
those over you can see I've got my eight
six three four which gives me twenty
eight thousand six hundred and
thirty-two but in fact this number here
is the same as this number here and this
number here is the same as this number
here so they've deliberately because of
course all you need is for those three
to add up to eighteen you've got a bit
of flexibility in there they've
deliberately made it so that whatever
this number is it's the same as that one
so if I want to do the back I just look
at this number read backwards so they're
twenty two thousand seven hundred and
twenty two I do always enjoy checking in
to see what brilliant orgs problem of
the week is there's a basic intermediate
and advanced let's go for the basic one
hey it says here Rakesh's spam filter
predicts whether or not an email is spam
it is accurate ninety-eight percent of
the time and he knows that one percent
of the emails sent to him are spam only
one percent a dream of that which is
more likely to be true if he receives an
email that his filter predicts is spam
the email is spam or the email is not
spam while you think about that I'd like
to thank brilliant for sponsoring this
video
brilliant dog is a website full of
quizzes and puzzles and courses you can
go through to get a better understanding
of things like mathematics physics
computer science they've got brilliant
stuff and by doing all these quizzes and
puzzles and sort of working your way
through it you really get a better
understanding of mathematics not just
memorizing things or being told things
you have to know but encouraging
critical thinking really getting an
understanding for things go and have a
look at the website and if you go to
brilliant org slash numberphile that
links also in the video description you
can get 20% off brilliants Premium
Membership and let's see if I'm ready
for these intermediate and advanced all
the intermediate ones got a snowman
you